empty whoa oh it sis I'm such a winner
hi this isn't anywhere near as extreme
as I was hoping it would be it's just a
giant pile of average how am I supposed
to be able to get in that hole that's
what she said that's what he said that's
what they said Wow okay this I'm not
gonna die dad he's riding my face not
die thank you thank you very much
excuse me oh god no oh my grandma could
do Oh God
hey you'll grab our son I'm my own man
take it nice and easy oh god not again
nice and easy
what I thought you meant by a burn run
okay Oh No well there goes my kid I'm so
I'm somehow did I make it
did I no no no no pick our food now this
this is what I'm talking about still get
off cows clothes language is good like
it's good
[Music]
where is the harpoon oh there it is well
there you go i won ultimate don't move
hanker do it you tell me how I should
moved oh that is nice fire but what's
the point besides burning my bum the way
that I do my splits
oh I'm a failure ok nevermind you know
I'm not good at sports hey look it's my
dog ha ha ha else oh oh wow again with
the face ok right back into it
577 - ever - ever - ever - ever - ever -
ever - ever new moon run easy supposedly
this one is so easy come on
oh come on it's easy it's easy that's
what it's motive easy plan trick
pleasure pleasure pleasure
I got your nose I got your nose Oh give
it bird guy all right you could
establish schedule so let's go to those
windows presents in posible Wow miss me
wow that did not oh no no
dunk yourself okay straight up like an
arrow obstacle course wait a minute
alright so I just gotta be quick about
it
hi gently stop go okay we're good we're
good we're good
and all miss me dick bottle run Chevy
Chevy whoa what is wrong with this
bomber run what is wrong something's
that right this is not a normal bottle
run now what I was expecting
these are not bottles you bastard
how far can you go in the poon runs oh
it's not just a poon run it's also a
bottle run and a record all right uh-huh
go buddy go I like your candor Howie why
wrecking ball yeah oh I see you there's
another one wow that's a bit too close
they're dead fall oh I'm still alive
those is my son I'm okay
Wow super pogo LAN through it that is
not it No Oh Oh get away from me no no I
want to live you just hide hide hide
it's not real it's not real this has
been happy wheels highlights thanks for
watching if you want to see more happy
wheels right now check the description
or click the annotation for the full
happy wheels playlist and if you want to
see more happy wheels in the future
please click the like button to let me
know thanks again everyone and as always
I will see you in the next video bye bye